so I'm curious Roberto you know I know a
lot of people that have come to LA and
some people end up doing the same thing
for years and stuck in a rut what do you
think separates those who make it from
those who don't know it's a pretty
general question you know sometimes
people will say and nothing supersedes
talent and I don't believe that I think
nothing supersedes diligent focused work
and really focusing and not you stepping
I think that I even I sometimes will
find myself involved in an endeavor that
has nothing to do with my book has any
do with my movies has any do with my
career and I just said yes to something
and find that now I'm like three months
in and it has nothing to unfocus you
know and so what I have done is I say no
I'm practicing getting better at it but
I say no to people come home he know
people are always come to me with like
really great idea that I want to start a
club uh we come help me and it sounds
like having skills to help you with that
of course I'll come help you but has
nothing to do with what i want to be
successful that and i believe that i
might have the skills but it's not part
of my career path and the people I know
who have been really successful have
been first thing they stay the course
and they don't beer off of it and and
that's you're successful you know famous
wise but successful financially mm-hmm
you know that they're that they stay the
course so not getting caught up in that
what is it the jack of all trades master
of none absolutely and just trying to be
everything to everyone absolutely it's
one of the reasons it's like I focus on
short film and short film format and I
work with future filmmakers all the time
off and out of that of that process but
I focus on
I spend most of my time watching
thinking about writing about blogging
about giving workshops about speaking on
pounds about short film yeah and then
I'll go to something else on making me
I'll make features and I'll move on to
that but then I will completely you know
I will move on to that and focus on that
and writing you this next book has
nothing to do with them I'm slowly
moving myself over and focusing solely
on that thank you